Speaker 1: All right. Well, Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez has COVID. And just days
after her Florida trip, during which Republicans
complained about her not wearing a mask outdoors
and about her partners feet being exposed in flip
flops and about her supposedly fleeing liberal New
York to conservative Paradise Florida. So there's
a bunch of different stories here that I want to
talk about, and mostly it's about the reaction
from these people. So Axios report. AOC tests
positive for COVID Congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez has tested positive, her office
confirmed Sunday evening. They're saying she's
experiencing symptoms and recovering at home.
The congresswoman received her booster shot this
fall, encourages everyone to get their booster
and follow all CDC guidelines. Also, a report
from PIX11 in New York. AOC positive for COVID
It wasn't immediately clear
what her symptoms were or how
severe. And that's really the only additional
information we have now. Marjorie Taylor Greene
very quickly took to Twitter. Oh no, not
Twitter. Where was this? This must have been on.
This must be on some right wing thing. Maybe
this is Parler. I don't know where, she said
so. Because Marjorie Taylor Greene is banned from
Twitter. Marjorie says super jab than vax the AOC
has COVID. What was that from all the unvaccinated
Republican men, she said, wanted to dater. Really,
it's because COVID vaccines don't actually
stop anyone from getting sick with COVID. Now,
that's untrue. As many of you know, three doses
is 75 percent effective at preventing symptomatic
infection with Akron and the overwhelming decrease
in hospitalization and death from the vaccine
continues to be obvious if you look at the
numbers. Marjorie Taylor Greene What also saying
AOC caught the pandemic of the unvaccinated
even though she is totally triple vax,
she shouldn't take that horse medicine, ivermectin
and monoclonal antibodies are for people who meet
certain criteria like obesity and over 55.
And that's not her. So a lot of very strange
gloating from Marjorie Taylor Greene, but there is
a couple of different things here to talk about.
Here's a clip from This Morning on CNBC of Andrew
Ross Sorkin and Becky Quick talking about it.
Speaker 2: In the meantime, New York
Representative Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
has tested positive for COVID 19. Her office
released a statement yesterday saying that she
is experiencing symptoms and recovering at home.
The statement also said that the congresswoman
received a booster shot last fall, but andrew
over the holidays. There were lots of pictures
of her unmasked out and about in Florida, and
she was already picking up heat for the fact that
it was kind of she was saying people shouldn't be
doing these things, but she was pictured doing a
lot of these things in Florida. So I think
this will be additional fodder for anybody
who's looking to take shots at her.
Speaker 3: You know, it's funny,
it's funny whether whether getting covered
now and I wonder whether there's changed,
whether getting covered is a scarlet letter,
I would think not. I would think there was
a point early on that people thought,
Speaker 1: OK, so so there's there's a
bunch of different things here. First of all,
these people now gloating are the ones who
haven't been following the guidelines all along,
whose rates of COVID are far higher in red states
than blue states in Trump counties versus
Biden counties whose death rates are higher,
whose hospitalization rates are higher. So why
would they be mad at AOC now? Well, because of
hypocrisy, that would be the explanation.
Hypocrisy? OK. Did AOC violate any rules?
And the answer is, as far as I know, she didn't.
She wore a mask when traveling down to Florida,
and she was outdoors and not wearing a mask.
And OK, so you could say well, but she's
advocating for things to be rules, which then she
ignores. No, she didn't ignore any rules. She wore
the mask on the plane. OK, whatever. So what's
the lesson here? The lesson is this is so insanely
contagious, and these right wingers have continued
to say, all of this stuff is B.S.. Leave liberal
New York and come to say Florida, where DeSantis
is doing everything great and it's so safe and
we're doing great on COVID. Well, hospitalizations
in Florida are up 200 plus percent since the start
of this hour wave. But AOC went to Florida and she
got COVID, so clearly it must not be that safe.
Now we're assuming that the COVID is a result of
her having been in Florida. If you think about
the timing, she was in Florida over the new year
and into into the New Year, and then she came back
and most people have two to three days
asymptomatic. Then symptoms start. Sometimes
it takes another day, two or three before you even
show up as positive. And then, you know, we got
the Sunday night, which was was the night. We're
presuming that this was the result of being in
Florida. It may not even be. We really don't know,
but it doesn't matter that the the idea here is
all of these right wing. It's likely that it
happened as a result of that trip and all of
these right wingers who say you got to come
down to Florida, it's actually safer here.
It doesn't actually appear to be. Also, remember
that we know she has COVID because she got tested,
and recently the Florida surgeon general
has been saying we got to do away with this
testing culture, you know, testing, testing
all the time. She could have followed that
and never gotten a positive test and just lived
her life and exposed more people and on and on
and on. But she's not doing that. She's actually
going to go into a quarantine. So without a doubt,
what AOC did is risky right now. Like this is so
contagious. You know, when I flew back few weeks
ago, every the entire airport was just filled with
coughing people. I don't know how I didn't get it,
but the people calling her out are doing the
exact same stuff. So the moral of the story,
it really is that contagious. And I'm going
to be doing very little for a couple of weeks,
and I want the peak to be over and hopefully
we'll have far better looking numbers in in a
few weeks. The other thing just to consider is.
It could have been going to Florida when she's
in the Bronx or wherever, you know, New York City
has an insanely high positivity rate right now.
She's meeting constituents, she's going to ribbon
cutting, she's doing all that stuff. She's in
harms way because of her job without question.
And ultimately, I don't know that it even really
matters where she got it. But that's the latest
Republicans gloating about AOC catching COVID.